„Jerusalema“ - zu diesem Song tanzen 2020
weltweit Tausende.
Wie diese Schüler aus Hamburg, Ärzte und
Pflegepersonal aus Düsseldorf,
Privatpersonen beim „Jerusalema“-Flashmob,
Flughafenangestellte aus Riga,
sogar Priester
und Nonnen in Italien.
Dieses Video aus Angola gehörte zu den
ersten.
Nachdem die Tanzgruppe es online gestellt
hatte, wurde der Song zum Millionen-Klick-Hit
und die weltweite Dance-Challenge war
geboren.
Der Frankfurter Tanz-Choreograph und
Coach Kelechi Onyele
war vom ersten Augenblick an selbst inspiriert
von dem Song.
Er erklärt sich das Phänomen „Jerusalema“
so:
Das Besondere an dem Song ist, dass dieser
Song sehr spirituell ist auch.
Der Song löst bei den Menschen aus,dass sie
Mut kriegen, dass sie Energie kriegen,
dass sie Kraft kriegen, dass sie gerade jetzt in
der Pandemie-Zeit, die wir haben,
dass man sagt:
Ich lass mal alle Sorgen kurz beiseite,
nehme mir mal kurz Zeit für mich
und meine Mitmenschen, meine Kollegen –
Chef, Putzfrau, egal wer, alle sind eins und
alle vereinen sich in diesem Tanz.
„Jerusalema“ ist die bekannteste
Dance-Challenge in diesem Jahr, aber
längst nicht die einzige.
Auf Plattformen wie TikTok entdecken viele
im Lockdown das Tanzen für sich.
In Europa und auf der ganzen Welt gehen
zahlreiche Choreographien viral.
Tänze zum Song „Blinding Lights“ von The
Weeknd gehören zu den erfolgreichsten.
Auch zu „Let’s Do It Again“ von J Boog wird
2020 in Europa und weltweit getanzt.
„Here Comes Santa“ von Snoop Dogg und
Anna Kendrick
ist gegen Ende des Jahres sehr beliebt.
Kelechi Onyele zeigt,
worauf es bei der Choreographie
von „Jerusalema“ ankommt:
Die Formel, die ich dafür rausgefunden habe,
– sehr schwer – ist:
sechs mal vier.
Sechs mal vier Schritte macht man, ganz
einfach.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, eins, zwei, drei, vier,
dann kommt der Wechselschritt.
Und so sieht es aus, wenn sich viele
Menschen
in der Corona-Zeit einem
Gemeinschaftsgefühl hingeben.
In Europa und weltweit.
Für mich ist die Message von
diesem Song ganz klar.
Es geht nur zusammen,
gerade in dieser schwierigen Zeit,
in der man ist,
und auch gerade dann, wenn man auch
glücklich ist,
es geht einfach immer zusammen.
Es macht einfach so viel mehr Spaß, wenn
man sich zusammenschließt,
egal welche Hautfarbe, egal welche Religion,
egal welcher Familienstand, egal wie …
was du im Leben erreicht hast und was nicht.
Es geht zusammen und zwar mit einfachen
Mitteln.
Man bewegt sich zusammen. Emotion kommt
von Motion.
Das ist es, was die Tausenden Teilnehmer
der „Jerusalema“-Dance-Challenge
mit ihren Videos erlebt und geschaffen haben:
ein bisschen Leichtigkeit, Freude und vor
allem Gemeinschaftsgefühl
in diesem ganz besonderen Jahr.